médailles de déportés de la résistance
les souvenirs de l'une des périodes les
plus sombres de l'histoire de l'humanité
sont encore bien gravée dans la mémoire
de raul durée âgé de 92 ans ce résistant
français a vécu les camps de
concentration décoré de plusieurs
médailles dont la plus haute distinction
française la légion d'honneur ce fils
d'agriculteur a débarqué à québec en
octobre 1953 sa conjointe et son fait
sainement agit de quelques semaines les
rejoindre en quelques mois plus tard
j'ai quitté la france parce que je ne
voulais pas que ce petit bonhomme vu ce
que j'ai vécu
il s'en est très bien tiré mais la
chance la chance d'avoir été peut-être
arrêter à la fin de la guerre et non pas
au début sinon nous serions pas là si je
me suis bientôt men vous avez même
peut-être pas tous aimé votre groupe
aidé le fils du général de gaulle sauvé
le neveu la famille de radio rai vivait
dans une ferme en haute savoie en france
avec son père et son frère
le jeune homme est entré dans un groupe
de résistants à seulement 16 ans il
servait de guide vers la frontière sus
aux personnes recherchées par les nazis
à l'issue d'une dénonciation de
collaborateurs les durées ont été
arrêtés le 23 avril 1944 la veille
rahouli un ami ont frôlé la barre monde
attirent et tuent mollet ballamou
siffler les oreilles mois alors nous on
a beaucoup moins
on l'a laissée là tout le monde on s'est
sauvé le nom lemay soir là la police
allemande était chez nous le soir vers
huit heures ils sont arrivés ils ont
arrêté papa toulon battu - ils l'ont
même ils m'ont malmenés ou c'est avec
d'autres déportés les durées ont fait le
voyage dans des wagons à bestiaux sans
boire ni manger pendant trois jours vers
dachau en allemagne le premier camp de
concentration créé par les nazis
les cheminots français ont été des
résistants extraordinaire et nous jeter
de l'eau
on en prenait un tout petit peu chagrin
ce qu'on pouvait être nommé
j'ai goûté un mât pis moi ça ne se voit
pas il faut avoir soif pour faire une
chose comme ça arriver à la chaude sur
le portail c'était marqué ici on rentrer
par la porte on sort par la cheminée
voici au numéro de matricule au col
dachau zion et psych lines en tige raul
ainsi que son frère et son père ont été
envoyés aux travaux forcés
raul a travaillé dans une usine de
construction de moteurs d'avions de bmw
quelques mois plus tard son père a
succombé à une morsure du chien d'un
gardien ss tout au long de leur
détention
les résistants durée ont été confrontés
à la mare où j'avais déjà vu des films
ou autres des piles de cadavres tous les
jours mes mains je me prenais moi et
puis aller de trois copains il fallait
prendre piles et les les porter sur un
étal moi c'était toujours je m'en
sortirai il m'en sortirais m'en sortir
et à la libération du camp le 29 avril
raul remarque parmi les troupes
américaines un journaliste francophone
qui deviendra plus tard son premier
ministre
j'ai vu avec ses terrains élevés qui
parlait avec les français qui venaient
d'être libérées les rues avec ici un
rôle à hawaï quand je lui ai dit que je
l'avais rencontrée elle vous avez vu à
dachau or il m'a touché lima school et
paul biya fait de son passage au camp de
la mare ou en paye 40 mille personnes
raul ne rapportera que cette petite
valise en bois il si nicole germain
radio canada québec